Ryan wood covers the Packers for the
Green Bay Press Gazette packer news.com
and the most recent article Packers QB
Aaron Rodgers plans to keep playing
working on details
Ryan wood joins us now what are the
details that he's working on Ryan it's
just the fact that after 14 games an
entire training camp the passing game
continues to be not on the same page and
the big part of that going forward and
what can they actually gain playing
these last two meaningless games outside
of playoff contention is that they've
got a pair of rookies and Mark was Vado
scantling equanimity is Saint Brown that
are going to be the future of this
passing game these are the guys that
Aaron Rodgers is going to be going to
next year and I think in Packer land
you'll hear a worthwhile argument that
they need to see what they have after a
full season to come Kaiser but the real
developmental priority should be on
these rookie receivers because like I
said they're going to be the future of
this passing game so getting those
details the the route depth the the the
playbook yes but also the the play
extensions that Aaron Rodgers does so
well getting that on on the same page is
going to be paramount going forward
here's my big question Ryan and I don't
know if anybody has the answer to this I
don't know if Aaron has the answer to
this what is the injury I know the groin
but what is the injury to the knee do we
even know he said yeah he said like week
two it was a sprained knee I asked him a
couple weeks ago if you know given time
the given that the possibility that he
might be past the injury which he seemed
to suggest that he's still dealing with
if there was more - and he said that he
would discuss that after the season so
he opened the door that there was
something more than a sprain going on I
think it'll be really interesting to see
if there's anything that needs to be
operated after the year I think that's a
possibility but he was he was coy about
what exactly the issue was look a nice
sprain is going to be three to four
weeks I mean we've all seen a sprain
before this injury stayed with them
yeah sure seems like a couple
so that's that's a heck of a lot more
than a spring yeah I think there's
damage in there certainly felt that way
when they were putting a brace on him
but the fact that it's lingered here I
just I can't put him out there I don't I
don't know what the upside is okay he
can work with these kids in the off
season Ryan I know I don't need him out
there in game situations risking hey
these are the future wide receivers of
our team I I got a deal with the present
I just can't have him out there against
you know this Jets defense this weekend
so yeah my reasons for putting about
there really aren't the same as what his
reasons aren't so what he said yesterday
when he gave his weekly you know
conference in front of his locker was
basically I mean he's not going to
undercut himself as leader within the
locker room he's being put in very
bluntly if he wants to be followed in
that locker room he can't cash it in
week 16 even if the Packers are out of
the playoffs
I get that argument because this this is
a guy who is as cerebral and as
self-aware as they come and he's
certainly aware of that players wouldn't
when they've left Green Bay I mean
former teammates have taken shots at his
leadership over the years and he's not
gonna he's absolutely not going to feed
that fodder he's not going to give them
reason to do that but those are his
reasons to me it's different than a year
ago a year ago he returns from the
broken collarbone he missed seven games
comes back in Carolina they lose that
game and officially get eliminated and
they put him on IR right away that's a
heck of a lot why he was still able to
as real assist in the injury was he was
still able to play this year so I I see
the case for something well for sure it
would be a catastrophe if he was to have
a significant injury come up in these
final two games that don't kow that
would influence the offseason or or even
2019 but that if they if they go that
round it sure seems like they aren't
going that route there is tangible
benefit that they can it's just it's
hard a year I think they could work in
the offseason but it is hard to
applicate these regular-season snaps
even in a game that does not playoff
contention in any other environment and
and for these rookie receivers it is
awfully important going forward just
because it has been 14 games that a
training camp and they're still not on
the same page yeah I just if I know his
knee structurally is sound and it's just
a sprain then ya go out and play I like
I'm okay with that
because I think he's gonna know what his
limitations are he's gonna protect
himself maybe goes into the fetal
position when somebody's ready to sack
him you know all those things to protect
yourself but if there is doubt about
that knee there is no way I'm gonna let
him go out there and play but who makes
this call it is Rogers capable of saying
to Joe Philbin on second thought you
know what I'm gonna shut this down you
guys publicly take the hit that you're
gonna shut me down that's a great
question I was thinking this yesterday
because ordinarily it would be the head
coach but Joe Philbin we don't know if
he's gonna be who's in arm obviously if
the next step would ordinarily be the
general manager and as you know for a
long time in Green Bay the the GM
whether it be Ted Thompson Ron wolf has
been the kind of desire of all football
he's been in charge of all football but
now Mark Murphy is really the person
running the football laughs he's a head
of the GM drive Brian gudykunst and the
organizational flow so I would imagine
this this is a decision that goes all
the way up to mark Murphy in some
capacity certainly Brian GU defense is
going to be highly evolved but if you
look at it from your perspective you're
right I mean if it has to even if it's
more than a sprain it does have to be
something where with me is structurally
sound yeah
if Aaron Rodgers says I want to play I
can't lead if I don't play it's going to
be awfully hard to tell him no now
you're gonna be nervous but this is a
team that put him out there really
really early with the broken collarbone
coming back off that a year ago so
they've done this in the past I think
that was more risky than this he's
played on this knee all year he missed
seven straight games going into Carolina
with the collarbone a year ago so there
was a high level of risk there so it's
just I
this is a case where air Rogers voice is
going to be listened to
he does have input and it's an
organizational decision but he says he
wants to play it's pretty hard to tell
no yeah I believe so and if he does want
to play and he wants to kind of gather
that locker room and maybe prove some of
these guys who used to play with him
wrong
I understand pride wise why he wants to
get out there Ryan we appreciate your
time good luck of the last couple of
games here at the regular season all
right take care down that's Ryan wood it
covers the Packers for the Green Bay
Press Gazette for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]